all the time i love that [ __ ] bro
bro bro oh my god i had the best [ __ ] i
we we're in the bahamas we're in the
casino dude like this is something i'm
realizing i really like because i can't
tell my wife what to do
so when like
people can i root for him
like like when she like breaks a rule or
something and the security goes like you
can't be here like i'll be like go tell
her you know like tell her like
get the [ __ ] out of here
so my wife was we were like we were
playing like blackjack and she was
trying to cross through the casino pit
and you know you're not allowed to be in
the middle of the tables right but so
she crosses she gets like to like the
middle and he goes i miss you have to go
back and i know already what my wife is
going to say because you could be a pain
in the ass no no
wait wait say it again i'm already
halfway
yeah
she goes she goes she goes and i
literally go she gonna say she's more
than halfway i know her little pain the
answer and she goes she i literally see
her about it she just goes i'm already
closer to the other side like i'm
already halfway and the second she said
that just to be a pain in the ass i was
like yo get her
you need a husband whenever we do
security there's a husband there's like
oh i'm gonna have a i gonna have an
argument with two people yeah yeah it
started with one
this one yeah dude remember and then
this mama's like get up yeah
you really want me to get ready for this
jedi
walk your ass
back i got support
yeah i know but you got a girlfriend you
got to protect her from security well
you got a wife bro you got to protect
her from your herself
you being a piece of [ __ ] right now walk
your ass back
thank you i needed that one i needed
this small victory
did your wife acknowledge you she was
furious at me because i was at the table
going do it
everybody thinks that she's just a
jackass no he's the husband right
oh you're gonna take his side i believe
in the rules
[Music]
that's how you know i never cheat on you
the rules
exactly yo that's funny
babe i'm only halfway in this [ __ ] is
that cheating
[Laughter]